alright Rob we're here today we're gonna
check out the third expansion of Call of
Duty advanced warfare supremacy that's
right and we're gonna check out some
more zombies on a carrier that's right
EXO zombies new map new weapon your
grenades new a lot of stuff alright
let's check it out let's check it out
all right here we go you're the are you
the new character too Hey look at that I
am the new character named Lennox who is
the way by the actor bruce campbell from
evil dead and the spiderman movies nice
he's pretty funny dude and his lines are
pretty funny as well um so yeah and like
you know that there's a major story you
know before characters with John
Malkovich they all escaped and then this
dude basically shows up who's gamble and
then at the start of the cinematic for
this one he just straight up shoots John
Malkovich in a freaking head and kills
him ever they're all like well why'd you
do that basically he goes well you
didn't know that John Malkovich is a
zombie and then they go basically
Malkovich turning into a zombie
mastermind the Overmind of all of this
it's weird like he seems to be like a
nice zombie like he like he'll give you
stuff um which is interesting like he'll
like here's a powerup or something like
that can't do a very good job not that
repression it's alright so it's kind of
like maybe he is off even maybe part of
him still wants to help you or something
but what's that now this thing is great
oh is that Plinko yeah it's freeing them
and the price is right so yeah you throw
a grenade in the slot and you luck out
on some points it's really oh what a
great gambling game right there I would
come on oh look at how small the window
uh oh so what time I did it I down
myself in front of everyone and they all
lab yeah what I grow what is the row
yeah Oh get there ah because this is the
new teleport grenade and it's legit dogs
already huh so how did that work it's
basically what you think you throw the
grenade and you spawn wherever it lands
is it more of a way to just kind of get
around with the map better or does it do
damage I mean yeah you're not throwing
them around your
really conservative the idea is that you
know it's like a last resort like you're
cornered you can't get out you just
throw that thing draw or at least you
try to throw it above and over the
zombies a couple times I've done and
what it wasn't able to because they were
just completely surrounding me and so
the brigade's actually kind of felt like
only like a couple feet away but when I
warped to that grenade yeah it does a
little like splash damage so there is a
new a weapon though right that right you
can gamble for the ld50 to limbo it's
just this orange beam okay so that comes
out and it looks like just an absolute
joy like I'm dying to get my hands on it
but yeah it just officially moves across
the whole floor this laser beam and just
dismembers zombie legs and that sounds
amazing looks amazing and they need to
get one my room I will do my best to get
it right did you get over there oh that
guy is not happy oh so that's what he
was yelling this is a door you just
don't want like the bio lab section is
something you don't need open up
immediately mm-hmm [ __ ] something you
learn as you play the game war yeah
right so that oh so what's that so that
is like a treasure bond or something and
you you know it's typical zombie fashion
to like basically lure you into death
likes is tempting you but yeah I have
how it has power ups if you follow it
long enough you can get it pretty
intense for around seven yeah again like
we should be in the hole you got it oh
yeah that's the limbo right yeah oh my
goodness wow I actually I didn't know
some like yeah turn I didn't know it
turned either that's insane that thing
is so cool man so you're looking at the
map to find out where the 3d printer
okay there is it's it's the cube there
in the hangar
nice how did he open it yeah you did Oh
teleporter that was it nice pretty cool
it's clutch well get out of jail card
right there exactly take money hey my
window shatter all right now I'm good my
chance we're gonna make talent at least
you banked it off and killed her what is
that oh yeah never oh yeah this zombie
sure they just tamed Sentinel zombie
mutated sharks Jesus that freakin besom
gun oh I wanted there goes your head I
want it so bad i mean that's like one of
the cool things that you can do in
zombies right hand to and like just
caught multiplayer because you don't
have to balance anything just like what
oh look at that see you see cut cut his
leg off like just Leia the motto is like
how can we kill [ __ ] like I think my
favorite and the earlier zombies were
like they had like that the wound of
often person like that it was just like
this electric gun right and you hit one
zombie and any nearby zombies will get
electrocuted and you just hand that
those moments with your buddy on a couch
we're like do it good and they go peasy
no no no I know doing it it's like are
you angling to do it I love it such a
panic and then he's got too crazy guns
oh he's I got the laser and you just
showed you a teleport grenade for
funsies are you gonna be the man who
opens the cargo door I'll do it what a
team player oh yeah it's you get to
empower I just need to move I like
that's the worst part right like round
10 and you lose your exosuit it's just
the worst feeling oh wow what is yeah
we're talking like this
you wouldn't expect it but now and
zombies you shoot dudes who are shooting
you so basically if the idea is there
Atlas soldiers and they come to
basically make your day a living hell
they will set a bomb that uh if you
don't defuse it will explode and the
infection smoke will fill the whole room
oh man this is a good combo power over
here oh nice this is that infinite ammo
mode in finao and it was also what's
that these guys I don't know I don't get
it awesome like what yeah just hit that
thing just ride it punch him in the butt
what punch Atum I just done gay you know
crew right there cleanup crew oh they're
gonna ride it yeah that's how you know
that hurt my next move is to get the EXO
ability health right there are new XO
ability as well yeah so there's also a
new one in its called stock pile and
it's like carry more more ammo I believe
you can tack on another grenade alright
shirt and make it a shot it should give
me a pay the man pay the man I'll take I
do you think that are the bigger the
hole the less you're getting out of it I
would like to think so kind i want to
show more skill if you got your like
more cred and you get the small arrow
make it even smaller hole fun reasons
Matt so hot ah yeah I've got your own
huh go get that thing distraction oh
that's a little alarm Oh bye
spoiling it I where's [ __ ] gun deck I
know where that is that's a nano
grenaded every yeah yeah so like toe
point is a clutch grenade but like
you're not really a team player right
like here you're doing your own thing
getting out of a situation all right
alarm obat help us haha oh yeah yeah
there's something else going on over
here you hear that the other room whoa
planned ooh is that DNA no explosive
touch yeah get them chop them up in the
grinder hello free money all right so
here's X oh hell Oh meanwhile money
nothing attention was money I have all
right so this is cool they have lot of
cool things in here oh that's not here
anymore just a leg kind of floating i
guess a club down hey man which is
trying to look at the scenery good shirt
hold of that like there's a guy like in
a suit one of those water underwater
scenes oh yeah oh yeah there's some
suits just hanging out in the Lotus like
I'm screwed this up Goddard is
gone so bad
dude his is green yeah yeah he's
definitely upgraded it so now i can get
this guy let's get that XO hell so now
you take more damage right before your
XO goes down yeah which is huge up comes
down thank Adam gah that's a guy with a
good gun too can't let limbo guide us
sketching buddy wonder he killed himself
with a grenade oh [ __ ] over there guys
there's a noise BAM that's actually
pretty good yeah right yeah yeah things
are legit oh [ __ ] they're coming they're
coming alright you take a second ago wow
you know the zombie maybe I'll get lucky
maybe a problem either way that grenade
probably killed a couple double
multiplier get that money Oh we'll get
the explosive touch you got the touch oh
yeah that's a pretty satisfying little
pic yet it feels great oh man that limbo
we need us a limbo
sure stockpile is yeah so this is the
new new XO ability yeah so yeah it
definitely added an extra grenade a boot
yeah for sure did and I am I don't think
it did was it always it always for it
was born to ya oh you are right you did
end up getting more with stockpile oh oh
you have three the the distraction line
thing and then you have five grenades
now nice gun is so cool that's why we're
gonna get one right now this has to have
two chances at this you son de we're
trying to buy a gun I believe rob
Oh an accidental yeah yeah all right
dude all right let's go let's do it yes
my heart rate just went up not hit oh
wow there goes an arm and a leg we gotta
get that bomb though okay i like it i
like i like that you don't care i like
that now you have a green limbo that's
what it's about oh the mayhem just bad
he's trumpet bomb detonated Oh No yeah
you didn't just replace your live all
right okay oh you just [ __ ] scared
hey man I had to know yeah line him up
oh yes it's hard to get a feel for it
like so it's not like a one hit kill ya
doesn't well you're in the later rounds
now too right right in theory if you
were able to gamble this you know like
eight round eight ten if I would have
been like level 4 x version of this
thing and apart would have been beasting
at that point right oh you can upgrade
it again in that room
like I is so sick your dad tee shots toe
box we do I get all I don't know if you
get a-movin yeah Buckley you do yeah you
do yeah you do oh yeah let's just sit
here and keep doing then away just keep
looped into the upgrade oh I'm so glad
we got this your shotgun tickles it does
not it oh I love it like the animation
almost like knock some back like a limo
game that's so funny yeah steal those
kills oh yeah a limited make it red you
teach teach and you have explosive touch
this is ridiculous we're they yet we are
they know the light show baby oh that's
fun oh you can't afford close it whoa
hello hey
so what a soldier do soldier um allows
me to now sprint and shoot okay coach is
pretty freaking big yeah hey guys oh
just losing limbs oh you're doing good
stuff I'm glad we got the the limbo that
sharda that made my day entirely that
was great yeah it's awesome so I mean
this third expansion pack supremacy for
call of duty events warfare two out now
for xbox one and xbox 360 right 15 bucks
or if you got the season pass you
already have it so new zombie mode new
multiplayer maps uh looks like a lot of
fun check it out there's a lot of fun
check it out kill zombies